taking its toll here in the las vegas
valley and those affected say
they wanted to stop murders have come
close
to doubling since this time last year
and many are wondering why
our sasha loftis went to metro police
for an answer in this special report
she just shined in everyone's life
a beaming light to those who loved her
michaela daniels
lost her life before it could ever truly
start
trying to realize that life
is going to go on but i'm missing a real
big part of me
she was shot and killed at just 17 years
old
officers discovered her body on february
2nd
after an argument outside a northeast
valley apartment
that's when her mother got the call that
changed
everything the scream that came on my
child's mouth
and she was like mama they said my baby
is dead
michaela's death is just one of many our
valley has seen in the last few months
murders and violence are on the rise
here in las vegas
so we asked metro police why when
somebody
has had a loved one that is killed
you know there's nothing you can tell
them that's going to make their day
or make it go any easier las vegas metro
homicide lieutenant ray spencer
describes the trend he says
started halfway through 2020. from
january through april of 2021
the department responded to 31 homicides
that's compared to 19
over the same time last year covet
obviously we think is playing some
impact he says the pandemic has pushed
many over the edge
but the leading cause of death is still
domestic violence
any type of assistance that someone can
get
that would lessen the opportunity that
someone would have to batter
or kill them is something that they need
to
seriously look into another community
concern
young people getting their hands on guns
you have
gun owners that are not securing their
firearms properly
a lot of burglaries because that's where
they're getting the guns they're getting
them from
car burglaries they're getting them from
residential burglaries and that's where
nikayla's family
wants to push for change too many guns
out there and that's something that
people don't want to address
they know no amount of time or grief
will bring her back
but they hope the courage to share this
story
will help others understand just
wondering why
why was she there and how did it
escalate
to something this drastic michaela was
more than just a number
to her family she was a treasure and she
will never
be forgotten it just hits you and then
you break
sasha loftis 8 news now
lieutenant ray spencer says metro
homicide detectives have a
97 percent solvability rate that's
well above the national average now if
you or someone you know is the victim of
domestic violence
you can call that number right there
1-800-799-safe
and we also have a list of local
resources you'll find that on our
website